operations unfortunately the three-bit repetition code completely fails to detect phase flips for instance supposing that we
encode a cubit using the 3-bit repetition code just like before and a phase flip error occurs on the middle
Cubit we'll obtain the state that's shown on the screen which is exactly the encoding that we would have gotten if a
phase flip had happened to the original Cubit before we encoded and so if we perform the same
circuit as before to try to detect an error we would get the syndrome z0 which wrongly suggests that no errors took
place so the 3 bit repetition code works for at most one bit flip error but it fails to detect phase flip errors in
fact it actually makes things worse in some sense because now we have three times as many cubits that could potentially experience phase flip
errors we've observed that the three-bit repetition code is completely oblivious to phase flip errors so it doesn't seem
to be very helpful for dealing with this sort of error but in fact we can modify the three- bit repetition code so that it
does detect phase flip errors and I'll explain now how this can be done here's the original circuit for
encoding a cubit using the 3-bit repetition code and the way that we'll modify it is very simple we just apply a
hadamar gate to each Cubit of the encoding a hadamar gate transforms a zero State into a plus State and a one
state into a minus state so the net effect is that we obtain the state that's shown on the screen where cat
Plus+ plus and Cat minus- minus are shorthand notation for the tensor of three plus States or three minus
States a face flip error or in other words a zgate transforms plus States into minus States and minus States into
plus States so this encoding will be useful for detecting and correcting phase flip errors and to do that we can
modify the error detection circuit from before in the following way here's the circuit from before and what we'll do is
simply to put hadamar gates at both the beginning and the end as is shown on the screen
the idea is very simple the first three hadamar gates transform plus and minus States back into zero and one States the
same parody checks us before take place and then the second layer of hadamar gates brings us back to our
encoding another way of thinking about this is that we're basically just transforming phase flip errors into bit flip Errors By conjugating by hatar
operations we can by the way simplify the circuit just a little bit this circuit here is completely equivalent
and you can check this for yourself if you're so inclined so if we put our encoda Cubit into this circuit assuming
no face flip errors have occurred we get the syndrome 0 0 indicating that there were no phase flip
errors and if we do have a phase flip error on the top Cubit let's say then the rightmost pluses and minuses flip
and that results in a different error syndrome 01 in this case that identifies the location of the phase flip just like
we had for bit flip and we can then correct it by applying a zgate to the top Cubit and the situation
is similar for face flip errors on either of the other two cubits so we can in fact detect and
correct up to one phase flip error using this code but unfortunately as you may have guessed we can now no longer
correct bit flip errors all is not lost however because we can in fact combine these two codes
together to obtain a code that can correct both bit flip and fade flip errors and in fact it will be able to
correct for any error on a single Cubit it's now time to discuss the 9 Cubit Shore code which is a Quantum
error correcting code that we can obtain by combining together the two codes that we just saw meaning the three bit
repetition code that allows us to correct a single bit flip error and the modified version of that code that allows us to correct a single phase flip
error to be more precise the 9 Cubit sh code is the code that we obtain by concatenating the two codes which means
that we first apply one encoding which encodes one cubit into three and then we apply the other encoding to each of the
three cubits separately so we'll get nine cubits in total we can express this in the form of
a circuit diagram as follows first we'll apply the modified version of the 3-bit repetition code
that detects phase flip errors and then we'll encode each of the resulting cubits independently using the original
3-bit repetition code so if we shrink this circuit down just a little bit to make some more room we can
specify the code in somewhat different terms by describing how the two standard basis States for our original Cubit get
encoded and once we know this we can determine by linearity how an arbitrary Cubit State Vector gets
encoded so that is the 9 Cubit Shore code and the idea is that one of the codes allows us to correct phase flip
errors and the other code allows us to correct bit flip errors and as we'll see that will in fact imply that we can
correct an arbitrary error on a single Cubit now let's see how we can detect and correct errors using the N9 Cubit
Shore code starting with bit flip errors which are also called X errors here's the circuit that performs
the encoding and just to make it easier to talk about we'll think about the nine cubits we get from this code as being
grouped into three blocks of three cubits where each block represents the encoding that we get from applying the
second encoding step which is the ordinary 3-bit repetition code that's called the inner code in
this context whereas the outer code is the code used for the first encoding step which in this case is the modified
version of the three-bit repetition code that works for phase flip errors to correct bit flip errors we can
simply treat each of the blocks separately each block is an encoding of a qbit using the three-bit repetition
code and that code protects against bit flip errors suppose first that an X error occurs on any one of the cubits
such as the middle cubit in the middle block if we independently check each of the blocks for bit flip errors and
correct for any errors we find then this error will be corrected and the original encoding will be
recovered in fact we could even have multiple X errors and still correct them in this way provided that the errors are
in separate blocks if we had two or three x errors in a single block we'd be in trouble but
as long as there's at most One X error per block the inner code will catch them and we'll be able to recover the original encoded
state so correcting bit flip errors is a pretty simple matter for this code we also need to consider phas flip errors
or in other words Z errors this time it's not quite so clear what we should do because the outer code is the one
that corrects for phase flip errors but we can't directly detect and correct them because the inner code is somehow